all right
the batman
i really loved this movie and i loved it
for different purposes
that i loved
other batman movies for this is going to
be a spoiler free review except for one
part at the end where i'm gonna talk
about the ending which i will give you a
spoiler warning before that happens so
don't worry but most most of this is
spoiler free i will be posting a spoiler
video on my other channel cosmic warren
which if you haven't subscribed to that
yet please do so i'll put a link in the
description and maybe up here somewhere
but i talk about other movies dc star
wars and other pop culture movies in
general so if you haven't sub to it go
do that so in this film
you see a very raw batman in fact he's
not really batman when we watch this
film he's vengeance in fact i i think
he's only called batman one time in the
entire movie for the most part people
call him vengeance and we see him become
batman
but we do see a raw batman here we see
rage right we see a little lack of
constraint in some parts and we see him
kind of mess up sometimes too which is
really great to see on screen now
we do see some of the constraint that is
typical batman like no guns no killing
and no spoilers but you know when some
other characters are about to kill you
know he kind of gives them that little
speech you know don't become like them
right don't suffer like they do don't
kill et cetera et cetera so you have you
have like the roots of batman there but
it's your two batman right and something
i love about this movie is just the
beginning of it the opening scene where
he's actually doing a voiceover which is
really really cool and it really really
kind of sets the tone of the movie in a
really really cool way
and you know you hear him say you know
i've been batman for two years crime is
up you know am am i making a difference
am i actually like am i doing a good job
and it's really cool to see that kind of
raw batman and in this film really what
we're seeing is batman discover who
batman is
that's what it is he's already became
batman right he's batman already
but batman changes right he has this
idea of who batman is in his head and it
changes over the course of this movie
through the different events so we
really see him discover who batman is
and i really really love this movie for
that because i don't think this has ever
been done before and that's what matt
reeve set out to do
make a batman movie that
really wasn't like any other batman
movie and he did a phenomenal job with
it now like i said the opening scene was
just phenomenal like it really started
the movie off in the perfect way and
again no spoilers but one of the best
scenes is seeing batman coming out of
the shadows because it takes such a long
time you just see
darkness
you see shadows and then you hear
footsteps but they're very
very slow they're not like
deuce here's batman coming up but it's
doof
and there's this little clink to it this
this little metal clink to it that
almost
sounds like cowboy boots right like the
spur of a cowboy boot and i think it
just adds so much to this it makes it so
much more menacing imagine if you were a
villain and you just hear all of a
sudden these footsteps and this little
clink and this really deep
hard-hitting footsteps and you just see
shadows and then after a little bit
after the anticipation builds up there's
batman right and his batman suit just
comes out it would be terrifying and to
watch this on screen is insane it's
insanely cool it's one of the best
batman scenes i've ever seen in my life
and that brings me to the visuals of
this movie there i think the visuals in
this movie are a masterpiece really i
could just kind of watch batman
looking over the city from different
rooftops for three hours long like
really the the scenes that we saw where
batman was doing that are awesome now i
truly love this film because to me it
was a very grounded batman film it's one
of the most
no it's the most realistic batman movie
we've ever gotten if batman was a real
life person right bruce wayne and batman
i believe that this is how he would be
and i will truly always love this movie
because of that now this also shows us
who batman really is the world's
greatest detective because this is a
detective movie and it has you on the
edge of your seat the entire time
wondering like what exactly is going on
which is another thing that i really
liked about this movie you never really
guessed what was coming now let's talk
about the tone now
a lot of people will say that it's
pretty slow at some parts which
yes
call what it is right it's it's slow at
some parts now the question here is did
you like those slow parts or did you not
were you falling asleep for me i really
really love the slow parts i think
there's a lot of subtlety that went into
this movie
in between the different characters that
i truly appreciated like towards kind of
like the third act of the movie uh
batman's you know in a certain place and
a cop comes up to him martinez and he's
like hey you shouldn't be here and
batman just kind of looks at him he's
like
and martinez is like oh
all right all right batman doesn't say
anything he needs to go into he's like
hey don't touch that don't touch that
again he like just turns me like
martinez is like oh
okay you you can touch it
like i love that and you also notice
that
batman doesn't really speak a lot when
there's a lot of people around like he
talks to gordon
all day all the time whatever no big
deal
but when he's around a lot of people you
notice that he talks very quietly and
doesn't speak very often and i think
like if you are bruce wayne disguised as
batman and you don't want people to know
that you're bruce wayne you're not gonna
talk a lot right and if you do talk it
is gonna kind of be pretty quietly
because you're not trying to get
everybody to go wait a second
you sound like bruce wayne
your best bruce wayne's jail like they
would figure it out so i actually really
enjoyed like the subtleties that they
put into this movie i i really enjoyed
it and it's something that you you pick
up on like the second time you watch it
to me it was just really good
storytelling like even even during the
slow parts that's why i really liked the
slow parts because it was great
storytelling now there are going to be
some people who think it was too slow
and too long and it's a long movie i
think avu is just a little and i mean
this like if it was just a little bit
longer it probably would have been too
long for me three hours is a pretty long
time but i think they cut it at a really
good time and the second time i watched
this movie i like
i was trying to think of
things i would cut like what scenes
would i cut what's unnecessary i
wouldn't really cut anything and so it's
really hard
to to go in and say like yeah it should
be shorter because i don't really think
it should be shorter but it is it is
pushing that limit of too long i i will
say that but it was just at that mark
for me so it was okay for me i can see
how uh some people definitely thought it
was too long now the cast
everyone's amazing yeah i mean
i think everybody performed at their
best in this movie i think it's top tier
acting in this movie everybody's
phenomenal and i i give them my highest
praise
for their acting in this movie i think
that's all that really needs to be said
about that like truly i give them my
highest praise for their acting in this
movie now the characters
because acting can be good but are the
characters necessary the characters are
phenomenal in this movie
and how they interact with batman and
bruce wayne is phenomenal in this movie
the relationship between jim gordon and
batman i i don't think we've ever seen
it like this on screen and i loved it i
think it's the best interaction that
we've seen between jim gordon and batman
like ever
i think it was amazing and you even hear
like some of the you know not bickering
but you know batman's like you trust me
he's like trust you
you know i've known you for two years i
don't even know who you are like but at
the end like he does trust batman he's
like yeah you're the only one i trust
right and it's just really cool to see
that relationship and then you see
batman praise jim gordon as well no
spoilers but you see that as well so
that to me that was a big part of the
movie and it was really really good
really good the riddler's puzzles they
were pretty fantastic it was uh
not
brutal well yeah it was brutal i guess
like because some people die in certain
ways that's a pretty bad way to go that
was like another raw thing is like you
you had the riddler with his riddles and
they were good riddles and you had like
the way he killed people was pretty
interesting you could kind of tell like
he's kind of a like a madman like not so
much like the joker but but you know in
his own mentally unstable way which you
could tell you know in some scenes in
the third act now
speaking of the joker a lot of people
are comparing you know paul first of all
paul daniel did a phenomenal job as the
riddler nothing can take that away but a
lot of people are comparing the riddler
to the joker heath ledger's joker i
don't think
i i think heath ledger's joker still
stands on top i think he still reigns
supreme as far as on-screen batman
villains go don't get me wrong paul dana
did an amazing job and the riddler is
great in this movie but i think for me
it's still heath ledger's joker i think
it was just more of a
i don't know more of an impact in the
dark knight i think you know he stole
the show and to me
the whole cast of this film the batman
is phenomenal and robert pattinson which
we'll we're about to get to um is
phenomenal and the riddler adds a lot to
it and he's the main villain and it's a
lot but to me like the joker really just
steals the dark knight it's phenomenal
so i'm gonna have to say i still like
keith ledger's joker uh more than the
realer but don't let that take away from
anything that paul daniel did with the
riddler because it was phenomenal now
was this
the best batman movie ever
that's debatable
it's debatable
i don't think we can really compare this
movie to other batman movies because
this is very much a
a batman origin movie that we've never
really gotten before it's very different
than any other film that we got before
because to me this actually this this
ties with the dark knight and and maybe
even batman forever because it's always
going to have a spot in my heart because
it's the first batman film i saw or i
should say it's the first batman film i
remember seeing
um
so that's always going to have a place
in my heart but
it's so hard to compare these these
movies because they are so different
this was by far the best batman origin
movie by far it's phenomenal it's way
better than batman begins way better and
i don't think we really need to compare
it to the dark knight because they are
two very very different movies
both of which i really appreciate for
what they are and they're very different
and i really like the fact that they're
very different movies because they are
different batman
now robert pattinson battinson
all the praise to him because
i think he did incredible i think he
nailed it i think it's exactly what matt
reeves wanted for this specific movie
could he have been christian bell's
batman i don't know but he was perfect
as
this batman perfect and again back to
the whole grounded part i think this is
how bruce wayne would be because you
have a lot of people saying like well
this is an emo batman like oh this is an
emo bruce wayne well like yeah like it's
showing us like the actual trauma that
bruce wayne and batman has gone through
like everything from losing his parents
to fighting crime in the city you know
for two years and like he says in the
beginning crime is up you know am i even
making a difference like it shows the
realness of it but i do think that given
the events of this movie by the end of
this movie he does seem to change which
i'm about to talk about but i think
maybe in the next batman film he could
be a little bit more of an outgoing
bruce wayne you know for reasons that
will be revealed in the next one and
that i won't talk about for you know
spoiler reasons i think that he could
open up a little bit more and become
more of that traditional bruce wayne
that people know but at the same time i
kind of like that he's not you know very
much a traditional bruce wayne so i'd
love to wait and see what they decide to
do with that one okay indian i'm gonna
talk about two different endings i'm
gonna talk about a non-spoiler one and
then i'm gonna give my thoughts on some
spoilers and i'll tell you when that's
gonna happen but
oh
this is the i think this is the greatest
batman ending ever out of all the films
i truly love this ending and i'm not
talking about the entire third act i'm
talking about like the actual ending i i
truly think
watching batman go through the events of
this movie and getting his mindset at
the very end of this movie and seeing
who he's become was amazing
if you haven't seen this movie i would
go see it
immediately as soon as you can if it's
safe to do it go do it
because i i truly think it's an amazing
film
again i don't
i don't know if it's the greatest batman
movie of all time because
i i think it's very different but i do
think it ties with the dark knight for
the greatest batman movie of all time
so go see that now okay spoiler talk for
the ending real quick if you haven't
seen it now's your time to step away two
two things i really loved and one i just
kind of talked about so i'll kind of
talk about there the batman going from
vengeance
to the batman from vengeance to hope
that whole monologue at the end that
whole part where
the bad guy says i'm vengeance and
batman just
he just it clicks with him all of a
sudden
he's been trying to be vengeance and
these guys
think they're vengeance and that's
not who he wants to be the same as a bad
guy he doesn't want to be the same as a
bad guy
right and then he realizes he's been
going about batman all wrong then he
jumps in the water and he goes and he
saves the new mayor and he's saving all
of these people
and it's so great how she's hesitant to
take his hand at first because he's a
vigilante right he's running around no
one knows much about him but then the
little kid takes his hand right
and he pulls him out and he pulls the
mayor out and then everybody follows him
and all of a sudden he he's their ally
and he's this beacon of hope all of a
sudden and then that final scene
where
he's holding that lady and he takes her
and she's getting air lifted and she's
like wait and she puts her hand on his
arm
and he realizes in that moment what he
can be
hope
he can be hope for the city he doesn't
need to be vengeance he needs to bring
hope to gotham and that's how he's going
to be the batman that whole scene right
there to me was the best batman scene
ever
i i loved it one of the best scenes ever
and then the riddler
the riddler used batman
and i love that that whole part where
he's in jail where he's sitting there
going
i couldn't have done it i don't have the
strength but you we did this together
and batman's like freaks out he's like
no you're you're a criminal you're a
murderer you're insane and then the
riddler is like no no what are you
talking about we're friends like we did
this together and he like has kind of
like a mental breakdown
that was insane to me i was like dang
the riddler used batman that's crazy and
that really was like i think that was a
pivotal batman movie moment right there
i think that was pretty intense so yeah
that is my review of the batman i loved
it um
i loved pretty much everything about it
it could have been a little shorter but
again i don't i don't know what i could
have
taken out to make it any shorter so all
in all one of the best batman movies of
all time is it the best i don't know i
don't think we need to make that
decision we can just say it's one of the
best of all time everyone was a
fantastic and robert pattinson did an
amazing job can't wait to see what
number two is going to be like so let me
know what you think about the batman
down below if you've seen it
and if you haven't let me know how
excited you are to go see it so until
next time catch y'all later woof